there's to the x minus one
you will notice i have included this
asymptote down here and of course the
equation of the asymptote is
y equals negative one right because it's
just like the normal
exponential asymptote of x y equals zero
but it's being dropped down one
because of this guy
i'm greater than greater so what does
your directional thinking tell you
above very good okay
so therefore to confirm that pick a
point for me
how about zero one
right always go for zeros always go for
positives the only other zero you could
get is over here for instance i'm gonna
be minus one
zero so i i prefer this one
so we test it out that's zero one so on
the left hand side you'd get one
and on the right hand side you're going
to get
two to the zero minus one which is one
minus one
right which is zero okay so is one
greater than zero
yes
yes
i hope one is greater than zero so
therefore the point we have chosen is in
the region
so we were right the first time it's a
bug
okay
all good
by the way just for kicks
you could actually rephrase this right
this boundary y equals 2x to the 2x
minus 1 you could say that's y plus 1
equals to the x how would you make x the
subject in this case
y plus one equals x would equal log base
two y plus one of y plus one right
there's the okay you got the indicator
there's the downward shift that we're
expecting okay so when you think about
the boundary it's going to be the
corresponding boundary is x is less than
log base 2 of that which of course is to
the left it's the same thing it's the
same thing just seeing from a different
way
yes you just need to be careful with
like
which direction your inequality goes in
you should be very careful
i in practice i would if i wasn't sure i
would resort back to testing it's when
you when you've got like a backup plan
you want your backup to be very reliable
right so i would test the point all
right in here um the first thing i want
to point out is when you've drawn your
boundary
please label them as these are actually
two separate equations y equals x and y
equals negative x you should label them
as such okay
as we'll get on to later when we look at
intersections of different regions and
so on
you'll get two different equations and
it's critical that you don't just say
the whole thing's absolute value of x
one of them is this and the other one is
that okay they're different what does
your intuition tell you
it's a box it's a bomb and you might
choose a point like the same point okay
zero comma one so you would say okay is
what do we got here
is
one greater than the absolute value of
zero
yes and the answer is yes it is so as
you said to me
this inside chunk is fine okay now
i asked you to do three four on your own
when you come
to five i haven't put in a boundary yet
right well sorry i should say i've put
in the boundary but i haven't said
whether it's included or not have a look
carefully at the interquality that's
been given to you yes or no yes it is
okay so i can fill this thing in now i
have some intercepts as well don't know
right what are the intercepts two
negatives
good yeah plus or minus two for each
because i'm at the center of the center
of the origin okay
so far so good now here's the great
thing about thinking directionally okay
again you could test the point
thankfully the origin is um
not on the boundary so i can just test
it and find it doesn't satisfy the
equality okay but a better way of
thinking about this is right
x squared plus y squared has got to be
greater than or equal to 4. that means x
squared plus y squared could be 5 or 6
or 9 or 16 or 25 or any other
larger value right because that can be
greater than okay so therefore like if i
thought about what those are equal to
those are x plus y squared equals five
or six or seven or eight right those are
circles aren't they how do they
correspond to this circle
they're bigger circles because that
number on the right hand side is the
radius squared okay so therefore what
that really means is you can be a circle
so long as your radius is greater than
or equal to
two
right so
that is saying outside outside here
okay
yeah i've got a sum okay there you go
right so
anywhere outside anywhere outside is all
fine now
six
is a bit weird is it weird for a couple
of reasons right the first reason is
you have graphed it you've graphed your
boundary line
y equals the square root of one minus x
squared
right
and
when i've got my boundary here
the boundary ends
i don't have any other boundaries well i
mean i suppose this one ends but
something else picks up where one of
them stops okay
this is the first one we've encountered
where there's actually
an ending okay
so just like i have with my number line
i'm employing the same kind of visual
language to indicate an end point just
like we have with the number line x is
greater than three okay
so this is what i've got here by the way
what are those values the endpoints
so this is the top half of the unit
circle okay now
we can employ our normal our normal
thinking in these terms right we can
think about a point right the origin is
not on
the boundary so i could say for instance
test out is zero
less than the square root of one minus
zero squared and the answer is yes it is
because that's zero and that's one right
so it's like cool
i've i've found that the origin is there
but then because unlike these guys right
it's like
having a point like here
right is that
in this region because like i'm on this
side or is it in this region because i'm
underneath because it's not closed and
it doesn't go forever right this doesn't
divide the whole cartesian plane into
two halves in fact it doesn't divide it
into any halves because this region like
it's all it's all one i can walk without
crossing a boundary right so
what does this
mean okay
now
i want to remind you
of what happened over here right do you
remember
this part was excluded why was it
excluded because the graph doesn't exist
good
um to be more a little more specific
because the graph is like well this the
shading is a graph right it's a graph of
an inequality rather than graph a line
okay so to be more specific with our
language the boundary is not defined
over here therefore the corresponding
region cannot be defined over there does
that make sense okay so therefore when
you come here can you see this boundary
is not defined over here
or over here do you agree with that okay
so greater than x
is equal to one x is greater than one
and x is less than negative one they're
off limits
i don't touch them at all okay just like
over here because the domain of this guy
is x is greater than zero right if the
domain of this boundary is between minus
one and one my region will be the same
does that make sense
okay
so left and right of here off limits
now
what that really means is i kind of have
a line going like this
do you see that right and i can't cross
there's like a boundary that's not
really well it's there but you can't see
it i didn't grasp it right but just like
i mean this asymptote told you there was
a boundary but there's no asymptote on a
semicircle or a circle okay they're just
kind of implied there by the domain
right it's not an asymptote i can't
actually you know
come right up to it
now
i have an answer right i have identified
that it's in this region and now i do
have a closed space in here right
and your intuition should have told you
that your intuition should have told you
it's y is less than that means
below
and voila does that make sense
and of course if you're if you're
weirded out a little bit by that right
you're like i'm outside the semi-circle
right you pick a value pick a value way
down here that would be outside the unit
circle okay
for instance how about you know this is
the unit circle right so as far as i
need to go is say 0 comma minus 2. i can
test that right
is negative 2 less than
the square root of 1 minus 0 squared the
answer is of course it is of course it's
any any negative value
i put into here
you satisfy this right you can go as far
down as you like
goes forever
had i said
had i said y is greater than
this square root one minus x squared if
i said y is greater than where would it
go
where would it go everywhere you just go
up above right it'll be up here
yeah that's right then they're not
asymptotes they're not asymptotes right
there is no line on this graph that is
approaching x equals one or x equals
negative one and getting closer and
closer and question but never going to
get there there's no line doing that
right
well it's a boundary it's a boundary
just like the this half of the circle is
a boundary right i can never touch it
but that doesn't make it asymptotic okay
it's just that's enough
yeah i've got a sun okay there you go
right so
anywhere outside anywhere outside is all
fine
and of course like i said i would pick
the origin too it's a sunflower now okay
love it um
yes it's the line and the nose and the
nose oh that's so cute
and the ears
no i won't be able to concentrate on the
rest i'll put it back off
uh i'll leave
okay all right